I was trying to sell dirty jobs in 2003
with no real success and the network
said we we do have something though that
we're kind of curious about which is
crab fishing in the Bering Sea would you
be interested in in exploring that and I
said yeah sure
and they showed me some footage little
boats big water cold all right and so I
flew from San Francisco to Seattle
Seattle to Anchorage Anchorage one of
those little planes that become a
statistic down in the job number seven
or eight there called Pan Air and they
fly you to the middle of the Aleutian
chain and you land at Dutch Harbor
Alaska
and you get off the plane and you check
into what looks like it might have been
a motel once upon a time and then you
get on one of these boats and you start
fishing and then you realize what actual
fishing really and truly is
20 30 foot Seas temperatures that can
swing 40 degrees in five minutes
um you want to talk about danger I
actually thought this was a misprint
you'll love this they they they gave me
an Actuarial chart before I went out on
the boat three columns
uh injury rates catastrophic injury
rates and mortality rates now I'm on
this little Pen Air flight from
Anchorage to Dutch and it's sporty right
right I got a bush pilot up there and
he's like saying all right folks hang on
we're going to give whenever you're
landing and the and the pilot comes on
and says Ah you know what let's give it
a shot right
you can hear the sound of your sphincter
slam shut and you're just like the
Pilot's gonna give it a shot because
like 40 percent of the flights that come
into Dutch they abort they just turned
back around and they land in Cold Bay or
some other place because you're flying
in between Mountains and the wind is
crazy so I'm on this plane being up and
down and back and forth and I'm reading
these Actuarial charts I'm thinking
somebody's just [ __ ]
this can't be true
what do you think the injury rate is for
a man who works on a crab boat for a
full season which is about at that time
in 2003 is six weeks the injury rate 20
percent higher 50 higher a hundred
percent yeah you're gonna get injured on
those type of jobs are correct Adam one
yes hundred percent yeah that's why I
don't do those kind of things I stay
here on podcasts and to be clear a
couple of stitches broken finger right a
mild you know contusion you're gonna get
knocked around for sure guaranteed
catastrophic injury right
eight percent wow six weeks so yeah uh
an iron pot's gonna slide across an icy
desk and shatter your pelvis all right
you know Jesus Mike you're gonna lose an
eye you're you're gonna dislocate an
elbow uh a helicopter is Gonna Come
Again flown by one of these poor
bastards down in California number seven
who's probably not gonna make it back to
drag your ass off the boat right to some
Hospital there oh eight
yeah okay the mortality rate column
three
it's not even a percentage they don't
even give it a percentage number
one a week
one a week right now one a week so again
one person statistically is going to die
every week during the six week period of
crab fishing on the Bering Sea now
people who watch that show which by the
way is now in its 20th season is it
deadliest catchment this is deadly this
is a show I've been narrating from the
from the gym yeah
um
they know you can't script the Bering
Sea we don't we know something bad is
going to happen but we don't know when
and in in that first season I spent six
weeks up there
when I left
everybody I met including me had gotten
injured
one eight and ten were eight out of a
hundred eight percent had gotten
seriously hurt
and I went to six funerals wow the the
Actuarial chart in 2003
for injury rates and mortality rates on
the Bering Sea was not in fact an
Actuarial chart it was a prophecy
and it came true 100 percent and when I
got back to uh to the states and and
talked to my friends at Discovery and we
all looked at this footage
you know we we realized that the
question you're asking is is not so
different than what
what do people want to watch like what
what is satisfying curiosity really mean
what this discovery
really mean is it is it limited to you
know how the universe works and planet
Earth or or can we look at what it means
to leave the cave and bring home the
meat like is that actually a thing you
can do on on television and when we saw
that footage and we saw real men most of
whom you know the lower 48 doesn't know
exist I mean nobody had ever gone up
there with cameras before much less put
them on a boat much less get to know the
deckhands and the green horns and the
captains and live in the midst of that
shitstorm nobody even knew it was
happening the pribilov islands what are
those what do you mean you're on 50
miles off the coast of Russia with 800
pound crab pots going over the rail what
do you mean you don't sleep for 48 58 70
hours at a time what do you mean six
people are gonna die in the next six
weeks like all that stuff was unknown
and and then all of a sudden it was
self-evident toward your future looks
bright hat click over here and to watch
the entire podcast click here take care
everybody
[Music]